[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
bueno
buenas tardes cómo están bien verdad
bueno les pregunto a cuántos de ustedes
les gustaría tener un robot en la casa
que les pueda ayudar en ciertas
necesidades que uno tiene
a muchos verdad
perfecto saben pero para adquirir un
robot se necesita de mucho dinero
verdad saben un día me fui a pasear por
ahí cuando estaba si tamaño más o menos
y me topé de que en la madre tierra hay
tanta basura votada
y saben que me da la idea de cuidar de
ella
y es más extraordinario ver que a
nosotros mismos somos quienes estamos
destruyendo la planeta
ya
bueno como verán muchos de nosotros
votamos al basurero aparatos
electrónicos que ya no utilizamos
como también muchos de nosotros
pensamos y creemos que para hacer un
robot se necesita de mucho dinero
materiales de precisión y conocimiento
un día mi padre me dijo
que un hombre puede marcar diferencia y
ese hombre eres tú yo me puse a pensar
detenidamente
y empecé a recordar hechos actos que me
hacen único en el universo y saben que
les digo a cada uno de ustedes que son
únicos en el universo y es la decisión
de cada uno de nosotros cuánto
esforzarnos
y saben que ese esfuerzo lo mínimo que
sea nos lleva al éxito
y nadie no los va a quitar
y un día me decía lo siguiente
este momento que estamos aquí es eterno
pero el dinero
es momentánea es de igual forma queridos
bueno un día la madre tierra me ayudó a
descubrir mi pasión y a cambio de eso
decidí cuidar de ella
la forma en que lo hago es lo siguiente
me dedico a hacer robots agricultores de
la basura
en cuidado del medio ambiente
quieren saber cómo empecé a dar vida a
la basura
recuerdo como todo niño en mis cuatro
años
quería tener un juguete
y a mi padre le decía en el mercado papi
cómprame este juguete lograda por el
juguete se aproximaba la navidad
quería tener mi juguete como mis otros
compañeros y mis padres pero saben qué
pasó
no pude tener ni un juguete en el
mercado
y mi padre en uno de esos días
antes que eso mis padres siempre han
sido de escasos recursos
ya
y no podían como comprar melón juguete
pero en uno de esos días
mi padre agarra madera planchas viejas y
empieza a hacerme los juguetes para mi
hermano menor y mi persona
y en navidad nos regalo eso
nosotros estábamos felices
al pasar los días mi hermano menor y mi
persona
empezamos a replicar los juguetes
en los primeros intentos que hemos hecho
los juguetes no nos salían muy bien
ya después de varios intentos hemos
logrado hacer hermosos juguetes que
posterior a eso jugábamos con ellos
sabe
en el colegio
había una escuela
era el único estudiante que iba con
abarcas en lugar de zapatos
y el primer día que fui
mis compañeros me dijeron me dijeron
guys quiero que significa el hombre que
maneja zapatos del indio
me dolió bastante al día siguiente no
quería volver a ir a la escuela
pero ahí estaba la fab la frase más más
sobresaliente de mi vida que me dijo mi
padre
no solo tienes que ser como yo sino
mucho más
y en ese momento yo dije
no solo tengo que ser como mi padre sino
mucho más
soy diferente por algo está pasando esto
y fui
siempre hay que tener la actitud
positiva
a mis 8 años
vendía figuras artesanales de alambre
en las oficinas en la calle
en esa plata financiado a mis estudios
escolares como también apoyaba a mi
familia
bueno no siempre me iba bien me decían
el alambre no era porque era flaca
sino porque hacía figuras artesanales
bueno al pasar los días en uno de esos
días un señor agarra mi figura artesanal
no es esta pero era una moto de alambre
artesanal y dice
esteban
si logras hacer
y dar movimiento a esta figura artesanal
que tienes te voy a pagar el doble yo
les dije que puedo si puedo le dije
esa tarde fue la primera vez que visité
el vertedero de patacamaya
y me ha ido me ha ido muy bien había
encontrado lo que estaba buscando un
motor
desde desde entonces empezar a visitar
diariamente el vertedero
agarraba las placas los equipos
electrónicos y empezaba a desarmar con
la fuerza del pie y con la piedra porque
no tenía herramientas
los primeros días no sabía que se
llamaban los componentes al que tenía
forma de arroz este se va a llamar arroz
que tenía forma de haba este se va a
llamar haba este tiene forma de lenteja
entonces se va a llamar lenteja
pero sabía cómo funcionaba por dentro he
aprendido prueba y error todo
empíricamente
algunas veces me electrocutado y hasta
algunas veces las piezas explotaban
pero ha sido un esfuerzo
y saben que parte de todo eso viene de
la disciplina siempre es bueno la
disciplina
ya bueno
actualmente me dedico a hacer
conferencias motivacionales de
empoderamiento en donde les digo a todos
los jóvenes
que no siempre es el dinero
y que sea y que a su gusto le dediquen
pasión creatividad disciplina y de
añadidura vendrá el dinero
bueno saben traigo una evidencia de la
creatividad y de que no siempre es el
dinero
para hacer robots
les presento
al wali boliviano el número 20 de mis
creaciones
[Aplausos]
lo hice de reciclaje
sin tener conocimientos básicos
todo prueba y error tardé un año pero me
inspiré en la película disney wali jan
donde wali va recogiendo la basura y va
cuidando el planeta
y de igual forma lo hice hasta el
momento ya tengo 26 creaciones
y sigo trabajando por un sueño y ese
sueño nunca se termina
bueno muchas gracias
[Aplausos]